what's up babies it's episode 175 of
congratulations here we go it's episode
175 and you know what I don't know I
don't know I straight-up don't know I
didn't record Monday because the world
was on fire I didn't record Tuesday
because the world was on fire I don't
know if the world still [ __ ] on fire
but it's Wednesday so I decided to do it
because maybe people want to laugh I
don't know I just I just don't know I do
know that the world is is [ __ ] and it
gets worse and worse by the day man I
thought covin was you remember kovat do
you remember coronavirus do you remember
coronavirus [ __ ] is getting real well it
got real and it had nothing to do with
coronavirus because people are rioting
and looting out there and part of me
wants to be like don't riot or loot and
part of me wants to be like dude I
[ __ ] get it I keep thinking of that
clip that Tupac said when he's like you
know well when you it's like opening the
door and seeing a party and all the
people are in there throwing salami 's
and they all got food and they're
[ __ ] having a party and I say hey can
we have some of the food and then
everybody in the [ __ ] party says oh
we don't have any food I don't know what
you're talking about he says oh okay and
then the next day you come by and say
hey can we please have food and we're
singing can we have food can we please
have food and you say oh we can't but we
don't know we talk about there's no food
here you come back a week later it's not
singing anymore it's give us some food
we want some food and then you're like
well we don't have food we don't know
what you're talking about a year later
two years later you're gonna be coming
in your head give me that [ __ ]
food I keep thinking about that clip
because people tried kneeling and people
don't want to hear that there were a lot
of drew breezes out there people tried
kneeling and that didn't work okay so
maybe then we don't need as many windows
I don't know what the answer is but I
don't know what the answer is that's the
thing what I know is I have no [ __ ]
idea how much racism is in the world I
keep thinking I know and then some other
[ __ ] opens my eyes to it I posted a
[ __ ] thing three or four days ago two
days ago I don't know about black lives
matter and I couldn't believe the
comments of it I thought maybe I should
disable comments on this and I thought I
on that [ __ ] it and I didn't and I can't
believe the comments under it I can't
believe the [ __ ] racist [ __ ] under
there and I can't believe it cuz I don't
know cuz I'm a white guy I don't deal
with the [ __ ] everyday you know and I
guess that's what they say that's
privilege but I had no [ __ ] idea man
I saw people all lives matter man it's
racist to say black lives matter are you
[ __ ] kidding me if you think that's
racist
put on a bunch of [ __ ] and put on a vest
with a bunch of hot pockets and go
[ __ ] hiking dude that is insane it's
not look I say black lives matter
someone says black lives matter and then
someone else says all lives oh actually
all lives matter and then you know what
I say I like bacon as long as we're
gonna be saying [ __ ] that doesn't
pertain to the last [ __ ] that we said I
like [ __ ] bacon also it's the same
thing if you say black lives that's the
whole [ __ ] point man it's the whole
[ __ ] point and I'm sick of these
[ __ ] telling people when they
can and when they can't protest like
drew brees yeah but you can't do it
during the national anthem because
that's [ __ ] you're disrespecting the
flag when would you like me to protest
excuse me can I protest what the [ __ ]
are you talking about that's not what
protesting is protesting is on the
protesting if you're doing it when
you're not supposed to you're the little
kids staying up at night after [ __ ]
your parents told you not to you're
protesting you're not protesting if
you're sitting at [ __ ] noon watching
cartoons after your parents made you
[ __ ] lunch
that's a protesting that's doing what
you spoke as opposed to protesting is
sitting in for
the TV with the squiggly lines in
between the two channels on skinemax and
trying to see a [ __ ] tit for one
minute that is protesting with your dick
in your hand
that's dude look all I'm saying is
kneeling wasn't [ __ ] working it
wasn't working
and I'm not condoning rioting and
looting I don't think that that's right
I don't think you should be out there
breaking windows and [ __ ] like that
but what the [ __ ] do I know I can't
imagine how mad and here's the thing
everyone should be that mad you know if
some of us have [ __ ] up then we're
[ __ ] up if some of us get [ __ ] up
then we are [ __ ] up we're not good if
some of us are [ __ ] dude if you have a
family and one of your kids is going
through some [ __ ] you're going through
some [ __ ] as a family it's just amazing
the people - it's hard to keep some
friends even I mean I see some friends
out there posting [ __ ] that I'm just
like really man this is what you're
gonna [ __ ] die on this hill and it's
hard to because you want to be in the
position where you're like you know what
I want people to have their opinions
this is what America is I want them to
[ __ ] be able to express their
opinions and not be cancelled because
[ __ ] forty people are getting
cancelled today remember Jimmy Fallon
nobody even [ __ ] remembers that
anymore that was [ __ ] eight hours ago
drew brees now because he said what the
[ __ ] you know and I completely disagree
with drew brees like I just said
protesting is only protesting if you're
doing it when you're not supposed to hey
hey hey hey hey hey drew brees what you
think about black people and black lives
matter well I don't think they should be
disrespecting the flag oh cool man what
the [ __ ] that have to do with anything
I like bacon I would love to be that
[ __ ] interviewer
so okay so you think nobody should
disrespect the flag well did you know
something about me I like bacon I don't
know man I don't know I just I don't
know I don't know what it's like to walk
down the street as a black guy or a
black woman I don't know and I won't
ever know you know I didn't know how I
wanted to start this podcast I didn't
know if I wanted to be serious or or
silly I you know I don't want to [ __ ]
try and tell anybody what to do because
I hate that [ __ ] the [ __ ] black you
know the black square that people were
posting I didn't do that
the what was a blackout Tuesday or
whatever god that was to me it was like
yeah everyone posted it all of a sudden
I look at Instagram everything's [ __ ]
black it's like I'm blind I don't know
what's going on and then I look and I'm
like oh you're supposed to blow it's a
post this in solidarity look who really
gives a [ __ ] what you're posting on
Instagram okay I get it
I posted a black lives matter thing
because I wanted to show my people that
follow me that I supported the movement
and that's good you know it's not bad
and then everyone started posting this
black square and and hashtagging black
lives matter and then people were like
you're gonna post the black guy blows
the black square otherwise your [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ] and then we were like and
then everyone was like I don't know and
then before I even [ __ ] decided to
post a black square now people are like
well you [ __ ] up if people it's a
black square because you put black lives
matter and it's clogging the feed and
now we don't know what the [ __ ] we're to
donate because we can't click the
hashtags and see where to donate we
can't click the hash eyes and see what's
going on some cops are shooting that
[ __ ] with rubber bullets we
can't see it we gotta click the hash tag
it we can't [ __ ] see it so you [ __ ]
up poke expose into black square okay
then you know what then my post is the
black lives matter one that was the last
one I did and that was the one where
these [ __ ] are out here trying
to get you cancelled man was a black
queer do it do it do it you did it you
[ __ ] up you [ __ ] up you [ __ ] up a
lot of it is about complying which is
weirdest [ __ ] man
like the the there was a [ __ ] clip
now and I had it say
then they [ __ ] deleted it were a
bunch of white white people were on the
ground
kneeling renouncing is that the right
word
they're white privilege they were like I
promised never to be privileged I
promise to do as well as I can and lift
up black people and it was like dude hey
you white people that's mmm that doesn't
absolve you you think it's that easy
that's white privilege you [ __ ]
morons
oh dude let's get together in a park and
[ __ ] sing racism over no dude I want
to protest against that protest do you
don't get to absolve yourself in a
[ __ ] afternoon there's 500 years of
[ __ ] slavery whatever the [ __ ] it is
and you think because you go into a park
and you're like I'll lift up black
people
I promise and then you feel good about
yourself you leave and you're just like
cool well I guess I'm going to heaven
you're doing that for you [ __ ]
and this is where I would be in a
[ __ ] audience and people would be
like mm-hmm
cuz [ __ ] is getting real remember
coronavirus man unbelievable
Tabora college was it's so [ __ ] funny
that some of these people just feel like
they need to post because it's a PR move
tube or college tab or college is
committed to treating all people with
respect because every person on the face
of the earth
matters to God treating people as if
they do not matter misses the mark that
Jesus set for all of us especially those
who are followers of him we desire to be
peace salt and light in our world of
violence chaos and evil we want to
overcome evil with good and bring
healing to brokenness our faith in Jesus
Christ empowers us to equip men and
women to be instruments of peace justice
and healing we are taking actions that
will help us live out this commitment to
Christ his kingdom and our society
several edges loaded and religion dude
just [ __ ] say first of all there's
some evidence about these [ __ ]
look at this guy tweeted Ted two for
college you threatened to every athlete
that if they took a knee and peaceful
protest they would be suspended okay
so then what side are you on hey paces
[ __ ] come on guys
just shut the [ __ ] up at this point you
you made your bed just [ __ ] stay
sleeping it's like that Lea Michele girl
dude I don't know her at all
have zero clue even really who she is
but I found out that she's on Glee
you know after the fact that Glee was on
and she was talking about what was the
[ __ ] thing Lea Michele said on
Twitter trying to look for it Lea
Michele find it k and find it one fire
he didn't [ __ ] show it to me
did you add it dude can't find it great
everyone
fired in the world can't find it [ __ ]
yes dude how do you spell Michelle yes
one L not how you spell it a yes got it
she wrote George Floyd did not diverse
deserve this
this was not an isolated incident and a
must end black lives matter dude and
somebody on Glee took her to town dude
she writes this girl's name is Sammy
where I guess she was on Glee - lmao
remember when you made my first
television television gig a living hell
because I'll never forget I believe you
told everyone what if you had the
opportunity you would [ __ ] in my wig
amongst other traumatic microaggressions
that made me question the career in
Hollywood God and 486 thousand likes Wow
how are you gonna go say you're gonna
[ __ ] in black people's wigs and then say
black lives matter obviously yeah you
don't think that and your tab or college
personified somebody wrote I worked on
Glee and it was not unknown fact that
Lea Michele was a huge bi TCH I don't
say [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
not even a whispered thing on set they
outwardly resented her I'm glad others
are now aware of this type of person she
is so sorry she's terrorized you like
this I mean I don't know about any of
this I kind of heard stuff about her but
after the fact so I don't know if I
don't know anything about it but that's
crazy it's so weird
and that gets gay and then she lost her
[ __ ] sponsorship with happy-go-lucky
or whatever the [ __ ] it is happy feet I
don't know what the [ __ ] she did some
skincare thing that was like called
happy [ __ ] go lucky Happy Feet or
some [ __ ] or or maybe was a good living
or eat eating healthy whatever the [ __ ]
it is every celebrity's got a thing
called [ __ ] good leaving good living
or eating healthy and they're trying to
hawk it with some foolish [ __ ]
shoulderless dress try new good eating
healthy living healthy healthy on-the-go
goodness try new
goodness of the soul I'm Lea Michele try
new goodness good oats trying to scrub
free goodness microbiotic and two
antioxidant free antioxidant full scrub
scrub it all over your face and then
you're good person tired of not
scrubbing your face with dirt no dirt
scrub for your face that's [ __ ]
everyone is doing that dude from
what's-her-name on down and I know you
know what I'm talking about when I say
what's-her-name it's a girl who played
[ __ ] electra and married [ __ ] ben
affleck the [ __ ] her name Jennifer
Garner whoa dude
she's awesome huh she she's awesome I
saw on Instagram doing her own laundry
lifelong fan oh she does her own laundry
though yeah man I love you Jennifer
Garner you're great I saw you at the
airport once and you were doing
something cute you were like going it's
trying to go to Starbucks and then you
really didn't have enough time to get to
your flight and you got out of line and
you [ __ ] walked away and we made eye
contact and you go like this and I was
like ah what a [ __ ] sweetheart I want
to be like ima get you make uhm anyway
Tromp huh-huh a lot of people being
saying some tone-deaf [ __ ] dude
how about Logan Paula came swinging
what he said was pretty cool that
[ __ ] thing people were like people
were like they were like that [ __ ]
the meme of the white guy blinking
what's that [ __ ] [ __ ] logan paul says
some cool [ __ ] dude and then and then
and but this is the one that I saw that
was amazing this was one that I saw that
was amazing her name is Lauren loves
veggies and she is an annoying vegan is
that a [ __ ] double is that
what'd he call it a redundant dude
vegans aren't all annoying but it
there's a high percentage of annoying
[ __ ] people in veganism of course and
i retweeted it and this is what she said
this needs to be sad here we go
anytime somebody says this needs to be
said guess what guess what it doesn't
need to be said ok
that's like saying that's like being
someone who's like trust me horns trust
me trust me push look what this girl
said I feel like this needs to be said
and I really wish that more people ding
ding ding ding ding ding oh dude that is
absolutely grenade material what dude
hey are you 11 quick question did you
come out of your mommy eight years ago
what hey don't ever say black people and
animals in the same sentence unless
you're saying hey black people look out
for those animals dude are you out of
your minds
dude I'm sorry but like let's just
listen to them how about this
don't [ __ ] say sentient beings to me
don't [ __ ] ever say sentient beings
dude what do you want goddamn robot all
sentient beings deserve equal of our
rights from black people two animals two
flowers sentient beings if I ever find
out what
an actual sentient B I don't know what
Adam what the umbrella is of sentient
beings I've ever find that out that's it
I'm gonna jump off a building I don't
want to know don't ever [ __ ] tell me
what a sentient being is I just say
chicken by the way no one no one
including people with different skin and
animals no one no one whether it be a
bird or a zebra no one also she doubled
down and said it again maybe she was
hoping that since the first time she got
canceled the second one would on cancel
her I ate chicken I ate chicken dude I
ate chicken and bacon today oh [ __ ] my
friend just [ __ ] tweeted under her
this is gross and tone-deaf and trash be
better think better read other books
stop this well do to read other books as
a good [ __ ] wow man hey read other
books spin move in you're out
jumping through a window
wow that's amazing dude how'd you bloom
having sex with a chick Wow how'd you
blow my back out that hard rid other
books sunglasses on
freeze-frame as you jump out the window
um anyway I cannot how can you compare
Wow well your congratulations you're six
so it's all good
but that [ __ ] was unbelievable there's
some [ __ ] crazy [ __ ] out
there doing it just burying themselves
drew brees god I love the people getting
checked too nice there's another tweet
from Nancy French Nashville is being
destroyed right now every brick I saw
every thrown without exception was
thrown by white people the man that was
yelling at these white people who would
put horse excrement on a cop car and
broke out their windows he said they'll
blame us and then there's dude
big ass [ __ ] came up it was real
ooh there's another one where the mom
was [ __ ] grabbing her son and
bringing her issues you get home
[ __ ] you ain't doing this [ __ ]
you ain't looting and rioting and she
was [ __ ] smacking her kicking
bitching out like walk dude what was the
[ __ ] other one there was another one
I was seeing I don't know I got nervous
said it wasn't recording anymore but it
is right it's red oh I saw jr. what's
the [ __ ] basketball player JR Smith
he [ __ ] beat the [ __ ] out of that kid
that tried to that broke his window and
his kid in his car and then I saw Jerry
Smith [ __ ] walking down the street
the other day like my life is a movie
dude I was like oh that's that
[ __ ] and he goes like this and I
go like this we gave each other the word
ball famous not what we gave each other
that we're both equally famous not what
what is that what is that dude
hell yeah you went Junior [ __ ]
what's-his-name Smith gives you the
[ __ ] nod you go like this oh yeah
that's dope what's his name drove by me
the other day the [ __ ] guy from Fall
Out Boy Pete Wentz just like hey man
there's a fire somewhere and I was like
oh yeah this is before this was before
the [ __ ] riots and [ __ ] say hey man
there's a fire man no I was like oh yeah
yeah hey what's up how's it going is
that yeah but it's pretty far I think
we're safe I was like ah cool and he
goes and I go like this I'm Chris I he
says yeah MP I said no no no I know who
you are and he goes yeah man and he
drove away
we both gave each other the [ __ ]
we're both equally famous not sometimes
you try to give a [ __ ] another famous
guy the famous nod and he doesn't know
who the [ __ ] you are though and then
it's not so much [ __ ] it's more fun
oh so yeah and that sucks dude but it's
all good at keeps in check you know
we're all humble you know we were [ __ ]
humble we are [ __ ] humble people
we're not that humble but um so yeah man
I watched that [ __ ] Jeffrey Epstein
documentary dude first of all I said
this [ __ ] about pizza gate a long time
ago about how I didn't think that was it
was a thing and I didn't think about
[ __ ] now there were there were no
pedophile rings in Hollywood and then
people were like what about Jeffrey
Epstein man this pretty good case closed
about the Geoffrey up written and I'm
like yeah dude Jeffrey Epstein wasn't in
Hollywood man Jeffrey Epstein was a
billionaire because he like [ __ ]
moved people's money's around and bought
businesses and [ __ ] and of course some
people in Hollywood are bad just because
[ __ ] some people are bad you know how
it's like I [ __ ] did to think about
pizza gay people like well that's
because obviously Chris I saw they got
hot he's a pedo well he's obviously
[ __ ] at something look at him look at
him look at him [ __ ] look laughs look
at him look laughs what he said it
that's something that somebody does when
they're a [ __ ] lawyer and but I saw
the Jeffrey Epstein thing and man that
dude looks a little bit [ __ ] I mean
that dude is a sociopath but the [ __ ]
documentary on Netflix it was called
like the Epstein [ __ ] files or
whatever [ __ ] it's called Epstein pure
money or some [ __ ] it was called help
Epstein healthy on the go is what it was
Epstein [ __ ] facial scrub grand on
the go [ __ ] green good for the earth
go leap directed by Lea Michele directed
by Lea Michelle Gellar and and and dude
and he [ __ ] molested so many women
and girls and it's so [ __ ] up and dude
the guy just dealing at the end of the
[ __ ] documentary and this is all you
can't ruin a documentary I'm not
the documentary the dot at the end of
the thing he was like he moved his money
around so the victims couldn't be paid
like this guy was such a piece of [ __ ]
and then he killed himself that's the
other thing too that I disagree with a
lot of people are when people are like
well he killed himself he didn't get to
live out his sentence and that sucks he
escaped the pain dude [ __ ] that
you know how probably can't painful
killing yourself is probably hurts a lot
dude but also he didn't kill himself
dude the cameras didn't work and the
cops were sleeping the guards and
Epstein hung himself by the way he
didn't even [ __ ] I don't even think
he jumped off something I figure I think
he just like tried to sit down really
quickly and [ __ ] hang himself and
broke his neck doing it and the coroner
or whatever the [ __ ] they call him the
forensics medical guy was like um no
this has never happened this is
extremely rare and that means it didn't
[ __ ] happen dude Epstein got choked
dude so guy walks into the [ __ ] thing
paid a guard what a million three
million four million dollars these
[ __ ] are billionaires that were
[ __ ] jerking off on a massage table
with high school girls you you wouldn't
[ __ ] cover it up for ten million
dollars if you got ninety five billion
dollars of course you would so they pay
them a giggle a guard just so you know
I'm gonna let the [ __ ] I'm gonna
change your life you're gonna be driving
around or whatever the [ __ ] foreign
shit's you want your houses are gonna
have the many doors you're gonna have a
pool and you might even have to just let
me get into that [ __ ] and choke
them please and they go like this okay
don't tell anybody and the guy says why
would I tell anybody if I tell anybody
then I got to go to jail too and then
they both [ __ ] jumped like the Toyota
commercials that they go Eila they jump
and they slap hands and they were
freeze-frame with their [ __ ] legs up
I love what you do for me
that's what happens and then [ __ ] he
goes I'll be right back and then goes
King Cole opens the thing and goes
tiptoes near [ __ ] Jeffrey Epstein and
goes like this remember me and then
[ __ ] chokes him so hard that he broke
his neck man it's obviously what
happened and I'm no conspiracy theorist
dude I don't believe in any conspiracies
[ __ ] of chasms razor or whatever
the [ __ ] they say it's probably what the
[ __ ] you think it is but this [ __ ] this
Jeffrey Epstein [ __ ] somebody
murdered this guy and dude I'm a
detective man I walk into the [ __ ]
Epstein thing and I go like this well he
[ __ ] he sat down into a [ __ ] noose
hmm something seems fishy Wow hmm and
you guys already think you know what
happens you think he [ __ ] killed
himself mmm Jeffrey Epstein killed
himself I don't know a little too
premature a little too premature of a
[ __ ] decision for my liking and then
put on sunglasses and leave dude out the
window and that Epstein was trash huh
there's other [ __ ] too and that
the [ __ ] documentary never told us
who it was they just showed pictures
they said one thing about the [ __ ]
prints guy and then one thing about
[ __ ] Bill Clinton and then they
showed one picture a [ __ ] Chris
Tucker and I'm like oh who did it I want
to know the other people that were in it
jerking off on massage tables with
[ __ ] high school kid I want to know
about these [ __ ] dude the whole
thing ended and it was like and I would
and we all looked at each other we were
like what the [ __ ] man we don't get to
know who else did it
expose these [ __ ] all they said
so many different times they were like
oh well we don't know well yeah there
were tons of other high profile high
profile people that that that tried to
that [ __ ] me and and when I was 14 and
then and then they were and they would
like show people on a plane and you'd be
like oh yeah there's Kevin Spacey but
did he do it but say it but did he do it
but say it oh there's a picture of Chris
Tucker but did he do it say Bill Clinton
did he do it say oh he was on the island
oh he said he wasn't but he was on the
island 26 times okay but did he do it
say it because you're saying Jeffrey
Epstein did it tell us man that's where
I'm watching the documentary I'm here
for the juicy bits I want to know dude
I want to know if Chris Tucker was like
color
when's your fit period I got Dan this
was a good the worst impression of all
time tally
why is my Chris Tucker impression tally
dude I want to do it if they had one
scene where's like and then Chris Tucker
went like this I would have been like
okay
worth it the four episodes worth it you
know how many [ __ ] pictures of the
[ __ ] house
they showed and the Jeffrey Epstein
documentary shit's so many pictures of
them of a tracking shot of his [ __ ]
West Palm Beach House I don't give a
[ __ ] about that show more more pictures
in the plane you hinted at Bill Clinton
you hinted that [ __ ] Kevin Spacey
yeah you said it [ __ ] the prints dude
did it - Andrew Prince guy and you show
one picture of Chris Tucker and you
think that's of Isis scheme' more pics
so I'm a b-boy who did hate chicks who
are women now who did let me know dude I
would be that guy man I am a tattle-tale
[ __ ] yeah dude that's why I respect that
6-9 car plancha guy cuz he was just like
oh [ __ ] I'm caught well they were like
well if you tell us and he was like stop
right there it was Dave and they were
like k well you're you're free cool I'll
be rich now
hell yeah snitched oh hell yeah I
snitched dude
man I think about that how many Bacon's
think so many times I know I've told you
guys about that but when I was in a
[ __ ] place called burgees in LA
cañada I would go and I would get the
tuna melt and I would say hey can I get
bacon on it and the guy would always say
sure how many Bacon's and I think about
that every two months
how many Bacon's and I cooked bacon
every morning because my girl won't do
it and I make how many Bacon's three or
eight three or four why did I say eight
oh cool
good cool got a tumor all good that's
all good dude someone call the doctor -
tumor I said eight and settle for sauce
organ after three by the way
oh so [ __ ] dumb dude kid let's do
these ads tided time to pay some bills
we got to do some ads here we got a [ __ ]
it already clicked out of the [ __ ]
thing we had the sponsor page up and we
already clicked out of it because I
don't have [ __ ] Wi-Fi or I have to
get rid of here because we're trying to
keep it [ __ ] free from karate even
though it's probably a disease that
doesn't affect as many as we thought we
did we're just kind of effects old
people and only like one or two kids
ever in the world but it's all good they
scared the [ __ ] out of us immediate
opposed this week's ads here we go only
got one a break everyone's getting fired
um-hmm cool computers dragon Bambi look
guys let me just be frank with you okay
when running a business HR issues can
kill you wrongful termination suits
minimum wage requirements labor
regulations and HR manager salaries look
I'm gonna keep on being frank with you
they're not cheap okay an average of
$70,000 a year yeah that's a lot Bambi
spelled BA MBE e was created
specifically for small businesses you
can get a dedicated HR manager craft HR
policy and maintain your compliance all
for just $99 a month with Bambi you can
change HR from your biggest liability to
guess what your biggest strength your
dedicated HR manager is available by
phone email or real-time chat from
onboarding determinations that customize
your policies to fit your business and
help you manage your employees day to
day all for just you're probably like
well how much does this cost
seventeen thousand dollars a month no
$99 a month month a month no hidden fees
cancel anytime
let Bambi help get your free HR audit
today go to baby calm / Congrats right
now to schedule your free HR audit
that's
be calm / Congrats spelled BA mba.com /
Congrats uh keeps you guys know about
this look when it comes to hair loss for
me it's good to take preventative
measures I use it and you look at my hat
and you're like okay well I guess I
would you do it do to be preventative
I'm 40 I don't know that's still super
young but I have my hair and yeah of
course it looks like a chia pet and it's
because I take preventive measures
thanks keeps two out of three guys will
experience some form of male pattern
baldness by the time they're 35 now I'm
one out of three of those guys lucky me
but the good news with today's
advancements in science keeps offers
proven treatments that can combat the
symptoms of hair loss and help you keep
the hair you have at half the cost of
your local pharmacy so don't go to your
local pharmacy for this go to keeps you
don't have to go broke avoiding going
ball keeps offers generic versions of
the only to FDA approved hair loss
products out there some of you have
tried them before but probably never for
this price okay keeps has revolutionized
the way men are treated for hair loss
thanks to keeps you no longer have to go
to the doctor's office for your hair
loss prescription now you can visit a
doctor online and get your hair loss
medication delivered to your home no
more waiting rooms no more pharmacy
checkout lines get doctor attention and
discreet drug delivery all from the
comfort of privacy of your own home if
you're ready to take action and prevent
hair loss go to keep stock calm /
congrats to receive the first month of
treatment free that's K EEPs calm /
Congrats hell yeah dude that's it that's
it for the ads so listen to why babies
oh it's the renouncing white real
privilege thing ok I got the note this
is it is this it
this isn't it this isn't it that's not
it
oh this is it this is it this is it oh
this is it about racism anti-blackness
or violence there's a bunch of white
people saying this at once that's so
creepy so anyway um I uh nobody talk
abut that so creepy so III our III oh I
dude I haven't done [ __ ] King speech
in a long time man that's so [ __ ]
that's so [ __ ] creepy so anyway I
don't I you know just do it I eat we did
that they took it down now but somebody
a black dude Andre wrote man I prefer
actual races I'm not gonna lie
and I [ __ ] laugh how about the
[ __ ] girl with the power drill that
took the [ __ ] thing hey what was the
[ __ ] power drill
power drill influencer or is that
[ __ ] thing hey where's that [ __ ]
power drill influencer thing I got it
here here we go so this girl Minh
Instagram video that this person [ __ ]
filmed this girl at first looks like
she's helping board up a place which is
noble enough and she's not this is what
happens she's doing it
then it pans over to her boyfriend
taking the picture of her doing it and
then she hands the power drill back to
the guy who's working she's like thank
you so much thank you for the picture
wanted the picture but didn't really
want to help what's wrong with this
[ __ ] world just so crazy like there's
so much wrong with this world boy Wow I
wonder what's happening next week
just [ __ ] a bunch of Jaguars are
gonna get let loose just just for the
[ __ ] that these Jaguars come from and
then newspeople gonna we're out here
live in [ __ ] where you're in Dallas
we're wondering what's going on cities
are just being stricken with Jaguars
just Jaguars hungry [ __ ] lean Jaguars
that haven't eaten in a long time
they're just out here
they have counted 80 80 in Dallas alone
and 45 people have died we're gonna go
live to Atlanta first of all upwards of
a hundred and ten Jaguars lead hungry
frothing at the mouth Jaguars are just
oh my god my leg cuz let me tell you
something dude 2020 ain't done dude it's
[ __ ] June 2020 is going like this
right now
they're getting ready bro we hit you
with the [ __ ] it's like the Emeril
[ __ ] coronavirus BAM riots Luton BAM jag
waggers spam emerald Ephesus Jaguar hey
if you said Jaguar [ __ ] get out of
here do it walk the plank
if you say Jaguar no you ever be friends
with a [ __ ] guy for like six years
and then hear him say Jaguar and you
were like well I didn't know [ __ ] you're
gonna run that by me maybe a little bit
sooner than [ __ ] six years you're
just gonna throw out jagwire are you i
but would you say croissant - you
[ __ ] cook croissant come on dude tour
Atilla kidding about that one
that's how you're supposed to say it
why some jag Wagar one time I was
walking in [ __ ] North Carolina and I
asked a security guard and I said hey
there was a Starbucks and it was closed
and I said ah man the Starbucks closed
is there any more coffee shop near here
and he says sure it's another Starbucks
down the block and I don't not think
about that once every three months
it's another Starbucks he [ __ ] kept
the block secure how about you get a
[ __ ] secure of the English language
dude hey how about you secure some
[ __ ] grammar dude I don't mean -
gentle gentle slam one time I had a
birthday party for [ __ ] Justin
McKinnon when I was in New Jersey and I
did it and I [ __ ] and I went but I
there was a sleepover I didn't want to
sleep over cuz I'll get [ __ ] scared I
didn't sleep over my friend's house when
I was a kid cuz I would get scared not
have to call my mommy and she would have
to come pick me up I was a big [ __ ] and
so anyway so I left beforehand but we
were watching a basketball game and we
were watching Michael Jordan play and
Justin McKinnon kept on saying Jordan
with the slim little kid [ __ ] he kept
I'm just going Norden with the solanum
and I would always think what the [ __ ]
is he doing why is he doing that nobody
was laughing or anything he was just
doing it for himself he's just like
Jordan with the slam and I realized that
that dude probably knew some [ __ ] that
we didn't know man that got ways free as
[ __ ] man I live to be that free dude I
got this shirt on
it says [ __ ] casual heck I'm sorry
causing hell and it's got a [ __ ] pan
Thor eating a horse and I just want you
to know it's because I'm badass that's
why I'm wearing it uh you know I know a
lot of [ __ ] things I say here are
silly goose time but let's drop that for
a second I'm wearing this shirt cuz I'm
a [ __ ] badass all right and it's from
a clothing company called represent and
I really like that company okay I like
it so much and it's in Britain or
something and man I went onto the
website and I tried to get a t-shirt and
this was the only [ __ ] t-shirt that
they had left now it wasn't my favorite
but I still like it there's so many
other t-shirts there's teachers with
sharks on them and there's t-shirts with
[ __ ] demons on him and [ __ ] dogs
and [ __ ] and a [ __ ] only got this one
when I came and then I saw another one
came out and had a truck on it and I
scooped that up and I signed up to let
them know when they restocked all the
other shit's all of them like eight
different [ __ ] sign ups and one time
I got a text because I said hey he's
back in stock so I clicked the [ __ ] and
I got the [ __ ] shirt with the shark
on it I got the shark the shark on it I
got the shirt with the shark on it
Jordan with the slalom and then I woke
up today and I saw at 4:30 a.m. they
texted me that the [ __ ] demon shirt
came in and I couldn't [ __ ] get it
because I woke up at 9:00 they were
[ __ ] sold out already so I'm like
don't be a bread and company anyway do
it what I'm trying to say is my life's
hard
it's a privilege so don I here with no
[ __ ] shirt with a demon on it
and I'm damn well [ __ ] sure a don't
have a shirt with a [ __ ] they had the
regular black shirt - I missed out on
anyway dude
and I [ __ ] even emailed them
sometimes you try to pull some [ __ ] I
emailed the [ __ ]
dress was like a when you guys getting
back in stock I said lovely stuff and
then I [ __ ] signed it and they were
like man [ __ ] it sign up so when it gets
back I'm like these [ __ ] don't
even know who I am man I'm not even
trying to get some freebie [ __ ] I just
want the hookups so I could pay for it
cuz I'm not in Britain anyway it's
whatever dude
so I'm a badass cuz I'm wearing the
shirt that says [ __ ] cause inhale and
I want [ __ ] to know it um dude
Alec Baldwin this [ __ ] was hilarious to
me this [ __ ] made me laugh okay I don't
know if it's supposed to make me laugh
or not maybe it means I'm a bad guy
except cookies dude all of these
[ __ ] don't call a cookies man
except cookies do you accept cookie use
cooked alright dude yeah what am I gonna
do and this is on Just Jared calm Alec
Baldwin responds to criticism for
promoting Woody Allen interview on
blackout Tuesday Alec Baldwin is
defending his decision to post on
blackout Tuesday the 62 year old actor
took to his Instagram on Tuesday June
2nd to promote his new interview with a
Woody Allen on his podcast here's the
thing dude of all [ __ ] guests during
blackout Tuesday he's gonna be like [ __ ]
it I'm still gonna post about my podcast
of all the guests he picked the guy who
married his daughter or whatever the
[ __ ] it is I don't even know what it is
Woody Allen's new book April apropos of
nothing
Apple April April Fool's Woody Allen's
new book April Fool's
if apropos of nothing starts with a
portrait of his father a tough guy world
war one never Navy veteran one times God
a one time gunman in a firing squad Alec
wrote on Instagram it's the first of a
series of surprising fascinating stories
yeah he added this is what he said the
interviews on thing then it says social
media users then took to comments to
slam Alec for interviewing woody because
of his sexual assault allegations made
against him
they also slammed Alec for posting on
black on black out Tuesday which is a
movement encouraging social medias to
users to stop posting so they can
educate themselves on black lives matter
Alec then fired back writing in the
course of this podcast this is the [ __ ]
that made me laugh dude on the in the
course of this podcast we have often
booked guests that have either requests
or required a specific posting date in
order to promote a project we made every
effort to honor these requests Allen is
no exception as for the perceived lack
of sensitive root sensitivity re
blackout Tuesday I had no idea about
this national day of whatever the
professional lives of some people cannot
be put on hold at the whims of political
correctness Alec continued I believe
Allen is innocent and that is my right
posting a black screen today or any
other day though a decent sentiment is
not an effective political stance voting
and working to enroll others to vote is
more dot dot dot practical this guy dude
I love guys over sixty because they're
like I'm just gonna ride out the way
I've been feeling they're like hey look
I'm 62 this is [ __ ] how it's been for
me I get the whole world I know that
there's problems I know you're gonna say
I'm a racist and I shouldn't be [ __ ]
putting people with sexual allegations
on a pedestal but you know what I'm
gonna ride this one out with the way
I've been feeling dude I know I like to
be a nice guy man I've only [ __ ] been
around him a few times I did that game
show he does you know believe what you
want I think the evidence is pretty
[ __ ] insane on Woody Allen but uh hey
man America believe what you want yeah
the kpop guys [ __ ] killed the white
lives matter hashtag and they just
started post and kpop I thought kpop was
[ __ ] ridiculous and it is and then the
white lives matter guys started coming
on Twitter and then kpop was like [ __ ]
you white lives matter guys and then
they've just post a picture of a dancing
Asian and I'm like cool good on you man
you [ __ ] saved a hat you've now white
white [ __ ] supremacist are gonna look
at the hashtag and I gonna have to see
[ __ ] twelve-year-old asian boys
dancing that's [ __ ]
radish [ __ ] dude you did it oh how about
the [ __ ] David Guetta thing let me
just tell you something about David
Guetta I don't know David Guetta at all
I bet David Guetta
for some reason is the nicest
[ __ ] in the world dude when I
look at David Guetta I just think now
that guy that guy's probably the nicest
[ __ ] in the world
I imagine for some reason David Guetta
is just a guy that's like to his friend
that's like yeah but trying to buy this
new car is is a you have here's the
money for the car I don't care I don't
know what kind of accent he has I think
he's French I can't do that one
but it's so funny that when a when a
when a white guy says a hint of a racist
thing he can be cancelled but when he's
foreign
everyone's like ads does know he's
talking about it's French
David Guetta goes like this first of all
it's weird that he's DJing because he's
DJing to nobody because of kovat you
know he's on the [ __ ] top of a
building
dude you're DJing for nobody just do it
in a basement somewhere why are you
going to the top of building alright why
doing that nicest guy ever
so anyway oh boy inspector [ __ ] clues
oh the world is going through difficult
times so [ __ ] general love it nicest
guy of all time wearing a shirt that
john farver would wear in swingers and
america to the world is going through
difficult times and america to actually
like america is its own planet love it
already
and america too actually dude when
you're trying to be [ __ ] poignant
leave the word actually out of it okay
so last night I knew we were gonna do
this and I made a special record so this
record is in honor of George Floyd on
this record is in honor of George Floyd
sounds like he almost messed the name up
we're gonna give it to him okay
foreign foreign we'll give it to him no
he's French
when already things are so difficult
this is where it really kicks off into
[ __ ] high gear dude it's like okay
okay okay he's foreign he's struggling
with the English language all good kind
of odd the whole thing's kind of odd but
then he [ __ ] immediately turns it to
[ __ ] Mactan after this okay shout out
to his family the guy just died you know
oh [ __ ] dude what happened oh oh your
[ __ ] dad died bro shout out to your
family imagine that a funeral and the
most important thing we have to do is
receive the shout outs from DJs so far
David Guetta has shouted out and other
DJs should follow but remember collect
those shout outs receive them and then
he and they drop some keys the beat gets
really but it starts swelling Mach 10 oh
you think oh you want to go to Mach 11
you want to go to Mach 11 shout-out to
the dead guys family you want to go to
Mach 11 do
[Music]
he remixed Martin Luther King jr. and
then did this I mean should imagine
you're in Vegas and this hog was on and
you were like dance with a chick they're
like yeah I'm gonna [ __ ] this chick
tonight dude I have a dream just a
[ __ ] huge boner up against her crotch
just like them you want another jacket
coke what you want another jacket coke
shout-out to his family don't do Bank
Bank bank the bank yo David Guetta's a
really [ __ ] nice guy he'll buy your
car if you want but honestly this is one
of those things where you got to give
the [ __ ] just you got it he's
raising money I think for this and it's
just it is funny and here at the
congratulations podcast aka cult we'll
all beat the LA cabin soon sharing ideas
but this no knock on David Geffen the
[ __ ] his name David Guetta but yeah it
does definitely seem like something how
about the [ __ ] oh dude what I got
did you see that the monkeys stole the
[ __ ] virus coronavirus [ __ ] is
getting real monkey stole it hey we
gotta get rid of monkeys okay like
straight up they have hands and they
have [ __ ] they like you could be like
hey monkey and they'll be like we got to
get rid of any kind of animals that have
hands right
what are they people you know I'm saying
according that one girl with the
tick-tock we're all sentient beings but
dude pretty sure we got to get rid of
monkeys
okay if they can steal a virus that can
murder the world oh you gotta get rid of
monkeys alright I would go overboard and
just say we also gotta get rid of the
[ __ ] band the monkeys but I think
they must be mostly dead yet or ninety
man I used to watch the [ __ ] out of the
monkeys do it but don't here we come
walking down the street I'm sorry to me
to sing that good but everyone we meet
among gays didn't mean to sing that well
dude I [ __ ] ripped that song man
people say we monkey around sing that
well dude I rock when I sing that song
didn't know I could sing that song that
well but we got to get rid of monkeys
dude they're gonna be stealing viruses
dude that's like that movie [ __ ]
planet the Apes dude
that was legitness it's like that movie
planet of the [ __ ] apes goddamn dude
monkey stole a virus you think that's
[ __ ] fake that's not fake news dude
monkey steal virus and they're just
chilling there's a picture of a monkey
chilling with a vial just like this
killing kidding monkey steals Cova 19th
test samples from health worker in India
hey dude I have a question why are
monkeys remotely close to that hey hey
keep your monkeys and viruses of far
apart and that's obvious [ __ ] monkey
with a vial just chilling in a bar later
does that you know what I [ __ ] still
what the corona virus the [ __ ] out of
here not really look it's right here
what why were you even close to that
yeah I don't know [ __ ] Indians or
nuts man that but monkeys near the
viruses near vials monkey shouldn't be
out for the monkey and I'll say it
we shouldn't even be near [ __ ] glass
period this vial right here glass I got
it
from a [ __ ] Indian guy really what
are gonna do with it
you think I [ __ ] know I'm a monkey I
might throw it or eat it or [ __ ] try
and put it my ass I'm a [ __ ] monkey
who knows what I'm gonna do with it I
shouldn't even be talking right now
monkeys mobbed an Indian health worker
and made off with blood dude what is
this world monkeys mobbed an Indian
health worker and made off with blood
samples from coronavirus test prompting
fears they could have spread the virus
in the local area after making off with
the three samples they took [ __ ]
three dude they took one and then either
this is how this went one took one and
then oh I'm not done yet took another
one and then he goes you thought that
was it and took a third one either that
happened or three monkeys took one age
that's [ __ ] a get rid of monkeys hey
monkeys you had your day great tired of
y'all swinging around stealing viral
viral vials you're out dude you go go go
go either I'll tell you what this is it
either get rid of all the monkeys or
dress them up like people and then just
have them out because the reason I'm not
doing this [ __ ] way hold on there's a
monkey out what what's the deal here I'm
either the monkeys gonna be us or
[ __ ] done I know I'm talking about
kill them all kill all the monkeys
there's gonna be no [ __ ] gray area
here if a monkey could still a vile
either murder all the monkeys or give
them [ __ ] driver's licenses dude and
I'm not [ __ ] around give them all
hats and caps and over I don't give a
[ __ ] clothe them if their will around
naked then the cops gotta take him in
for indecent exposure I'll talk about
monkeys or people now you thought that
the [ __ ] coronavirus was [ __ ]
monkeys are people okay dress them up
put pants on that monkey hey I got the
reviles really yeah
monkey run away with corona test samples
locals furia here's a video of it he's
up in the tree where there he's up in
the tree
oh how [ __ ] nervous do they sound
okay oh hey man the monkey has the vial
the guy's gonna [ __ ] it right I've got
it dude imagine [ __ ] we need our top
line of defense yeah [ __ ] who we gonna
come I got the guy to call and a badass
comes in like a Jason Statham on a
[ __ ] motorcycle or in like a [ __ ]
McLaren and he pulls up and he pops out
he's like I got this and walks up to the
monkey and he's like guys stand back
[Laughter]
[ __ ] even Jason state even the Indian
Jason Statham couldn't do it no no no I
got it guys stand back [ __ ] there we go
so I'm running after him I got a monkey
we're gonna kill your prepared onion
[ __ ] he's got three vials [ __ ] there's
two more with two more vials guys just
in different directions there's three of
them and one monkey falls for it guys
she's doing that guys I'll be right back
I just wanna go see what he wants maybe
he's got bread or something no don't
fall for it no no it's gonna be fine
it's gonna be fine him get closer got
him get the vial off [ __ ] ah get away I
knew he didn't have bread go running out
if I could she running out of a building
like it's fast and furious jumped from
one building through a window into
another building slow motion in the air
the monkeys got the viral vial [ __ ]
making it into the window another and
[ __ ] the Indian Jason Statham it just
follows them out of the [ __ ] air in
slow motion just like this in slow
motion
[Laughter]
[Music]
I got one of the files left but they're
still [ __ ] 90 minutes left in this
movie and we need to get to more dress
him up [ __ ]
alright babies I think that's it we'll
end on that one you guys keep it safe
out there protesting peacefully is
amazing we love it that's what is part
of America black lives matter spread the
word and thanks for listening man we did
get a little silly I wasn't sure how
this podcast was going to go because
I've been so upset you know and the
world's going through some weird [ __ ]
but change is needed and monkey still
[ __ ] the coronavirus so we got out we
got to make sure that everything is
figured out alright guys thanks for
listening and you can text me my link is
on my Instagram page if you go to my
home page you can text me and watch my
special no pain ok guys thanks so much
you guys are the best bye bye
[Music]